الامريكيه نشرت تحقيقا حول انتشار مجموعه
فاجنر الامنيه الروسيه في افريقيا وقالت
ان الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين يسعى
لتعميق نفوذ بلاده في القاره وفي السنوات
الاخيره وسعت فاجنر بثبات نفوذها السياسيه
والعسكريه والاقتصاديه في افريقيا وفي
المقابل رفضت العديد من الدول الافريقيه
ادانه الهجوم الروسيه على اوكرانيا او
الانضمام الى العقوبات الغربيه ضد موسكو
الصحيفه الامريكيه تابعت تقريرا سيصدر هذا
الاسبوع للامم المتحده قالت فيه المنظمه
الدوليه ان عناصر من مدربين ومقاتلين
عملوا مع جنود محليين في جمهوريه افريقيا
الوسطى لشن هجمات تهدف الى السيطره على
اربع مناطق على الاقل معروفه بمناجم الماس
مع دعم السلطات بالطائرات العسكريه ايضا
اشار مسؤول استخبارات غربيون الى ان
مجموعه فاجنر تدرب مجموعه مسلحه في تشاد
التي تربط حكومه البلاد علاقات وثيقه
بفرنسا في محاوله للحصول على موقع قدم في
تشاد
وعلى الصعيد السياسي زار وزير الخارجيه
الروسي سالي فيما اعتبر مؤشرا على دفء
العلاقات بين الكرملين والحكومه العسكريه
التي استولت على السلطه قبل عامين وقال
لابروف ان هناك شاف فرص التعدين لشركات
الروسيه في مالي مشيرا بالظروف المريحه
التي يتم توفيرها للشركات الروسيه العامله
في البلاد واهمها مشروع مشترك بقياده شركه